the sussexes make big moves to protect
the monarchy welcome everybody to
Entertainment Tonight Kevin's off today
now before the death of the queen Harry
and Megan distanced themselves from the
royal family but now it seems their
sudden change of heart may be too little
too late
I think it is a case of the palace
really preparing themselves for what's
to come
panicked having second thoughts and at
odds with Netflix according to multiple
reports Harry and Megan are said to be
clashing with Netflix bosses over their
upcoming docu-series the stories claim
the couple want to walk back comments
they made about King Charles and Camilla
there's a lot at stake the couple
reportedly signed a 100 million dollar
deal and according to Katie nickel
author of the new Royals Harry got a 35
million dollar advance for his upcoming
Memoir yeah and 35 million dollars I
would think that kind of money talks
when you're having that sort of an
advance that's not going to be for Harry
talking about his philanthropic work
Netflix cameras reportedly followed
Harry and Megan during visits to Holland
and New York in Harlem photog spotted a
microphone wire sticking out of Harry's
pocket there are big issues that need to
be sorted out and not least the fact
that Harry and Megan keep reaching the
confidence and Trust of the royal family
I thought my family would help but every
single
ask requests warning whatever it is just
got met with total silence or total
neglect
what's going to happen with the titles
of Archie and Lily Bird right if Charles
gives them those titles and I think it's
a big if that comes with a cost that's
going to come with an expectation of
loyalty and Trust meanwhile Harry's
brother William made a surprise visit
with Kate to Northern Ireland
the crowd cheered for the new Prince and
Princess of Wales and Kate was presented
with flowers a bit later they took part
in a friendly bartending battle then
sipped on the job the next big Royal
event King Charles's coronation I shall
Endeavor to serve you with loyalty
respect and love a new report claims the
ceremony will be in eight months on June
3rd but we're hearing at this point that
speculation and no date has been agreed
upon but one Royal details seems certain
I think we're going to see the entire
coronation when that comes be televised
you know Charles has to have that
connection with the people in order I
think to be seen as relevant
[Music]